i lost my aunt to breast cancer and that
has crossed my mind a bit when i've gone
in for my annual appointments
however i haven't let that stop me from
being sure about my health
and i don't think anyone else should
either black women are often very
private
we don't want people knowing our
business but the more we open up
the more it allows us to share
information that can be life-saving
and that's why mary j blige is doing
this because she wants to save lives
hello mary j blige this is so important
that you're doing this
hello gail hey really good to see you
you good to see you
you talk in the psa that you had your
first mammogram
in your 40s and that you didn't know
what to expect and i know that moment
you walk in that room and you look at
that machine and you say
you're going to squeeze what with what
and how flat is it going to be and how
does this work
because it is very daunting when you
look at the apparatus
so do you recall that first experience
and what it was really like for you
yeah my first experience i was a little
nervous because
not just the fact that you know it isn't
going to hurt
but just getting diagnosed with breath
breast cancer like
you know who wants to walk away with
that um news
but um once i did it you know it was all
about
wanting more information about my body
one now i want to know
everything about me you know because now
if i can see it you know when the 3d
mammographies or the x-rays x-rays
then you know i can change it and it's
all about being able to
it's about knowledge you know knowledge
about your body knowledge about
how a mammogram could save your life his
power that's why i'm here
you say your health is your wealth and
you know mary that moment when you're
sitting there waiting for the results
and the doctor walks in and you're
trying to look at their face for what
what is the thing i always say
could you smile when you walk in the
room they walk in the room to give you
the news
yes you're okay or no we need to do some
more tests but you said
if your aunt had had this information
possibly her life could have been saved
because according to the cdc
breast cancer death rates are 40 percent
higher among black women
than white women exactly
and um like i i believe if my unhad this
information
she would be alive i mean a lot of us
when we're growing up
and in our home in our households our
mothers don't mention mammograms or
you know the importance of it or even
breast cancer a family member just
ups and dies and then later you found
out they had breast cancer
so just with me going and having the
information that i have
there's a bunch of women that love and
respect
you know just everything that i do and i
just always want to share with them
you know not preached to them just me
being an example
of you know healthy healthy healthy
living just trying to live healthy and
this is a part of it
mm-hmm mary's anthony mason i we're
talking about some very important health
issues here and i wanted to talk about
mental health in this corona virus
because i read
that that mary j blige was going back
and listening to a lot of mary j blige
music
something maybe you don't often do and
and what you heard in that and and what
you took from it man
i took a lot of learning how to be
patient especially from my life there's
this line where it says um
uh take your time one day at a time it's
all on you what you gonna do
and in the middle of the pandemic it's
like what else can we do
except for take our time one day at a
time
we can't go anywhere we can't really see
our family members so
we just have to pray we just have to be
patient and pray for patients and
so yeah and you know it was definitely
it was definitely my life and just
my lyrics you know ministering back to
me and
and giving me inspiration are you are
you feeling
are you feeling more creative at this
point of time or more sort of
a lot of people feel very shut down you
know i
i was in the pandemic feeling more
creative because
there's so much to say there's there's
so much to there's so
there's so much to do and there's so
much love to give
at a point like this because you can't
really hate because it can just
it could kill you at a time like this
but it's so much love to give there's so
many things to write about it's so
and i and i i'm always inspired by real
life
to in my song so this was real life i
mean not that life wasn't real but this
was like
whoa and you know yeah you can speak
negative about it or you can speak
optimistically about it
and um i try to speak optimistically
but practical too about it you know when
i'm writing my lyrics because
you can't just be like it's all good
because it's not but you can say
we will get to the other side that's why
it's good to put on a good old mary j
blige song she will get you through many
things mary j blige i have to say
but this just happened right before you
came on megan the stallion wrote a very
powerful op-ed in the new york times
today
she says i was recently the victim of an
act of violence by a man
at a party i was shot twice i walked
away from him i was not in a
relationship
and then she goes on to say the way
people have publicly questioned and
debated
whether i played a role in my own
violent assault proves
that my fears about discussing what
happened were unfortunately warranted
and this is a line that gets to me
the issue is even more intense for black
women who struggle against stereotypes
and are seen as angry and threatening
when we try to stand up for ourselves
and our sisters
there is not much room for passionate
advocacy if you are
a black woman i just thought bravo megan
for writing it
and i'm curious about your reaction upon
hearing it i'm just reading it too for
the first time
well i mean i this is my first time
hearing it yeah i love me
i love megan the stallion i respect her
she's a beautiful person
a strong woman and um she's ahead of the
game already because
she understands what this game is you
have to be
you have to be private as public you are
as you are people
see your life publicly you have to be
private and you can't give everyone
everything
it's as much as people think they know
about me a lot of people know
a lot about me because i've been really
open and transparent but
they don't know a lot about me but she's
talking mary about the minimalization of
black women that i think is very
important to address
does that resonate with you at all
well i mean it i mean it does
and and bravo to her for understanding
that
for understanding and speaking it it's
very it's in the new york times today i
highly highly highly recommend people
read it
mary j blige thank you and bravo to you
for doing this
you are going to save many lives you're
going to get people who will get a
mammogram who had never thought about it
before
and that's huge thanks a lot thank you
thank you
good to see you